the head of the CIA told CBS news that
he's quote confident China is
considering sending weapons to Russia
for the Ukraine war William Byrne spoke
exclusively to face a Nation about the
latest intelligence as President Biden
warns of the potential major
consequences if China takes that step
Nancy Cordes is at the White House with
more on this part of the story Nancy
good morning this could be a game
changer not in a good way
that's right Gail the CIA director told
CBS news that the agency has begun to
collect intelligence that indicates that
China is considering giving weapons to
Russia now he didn't share the source of
that intelligence but he said that U.S
officials are going public with it now
in a hopes of deterring Chinese
officials from doing it
we remain seriously concerned should
China provide lethal equipment to Russia
CIA director William Burns told Face the
Nation moderator Margaret Brennan that
the U.S has not seen evidence that China
has actually shipped any weapons to
Russia yet I think the Chinese are also
trying to weigh the consequences
President Biden made it clear last week
what would happen if the Chinese crossed
that line we I'm imposed severe
sanctions on anyone who has done that
as the war grinds on past the one year
mark with no end in sight Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski and some
allies are pushing the president to send
new weapons including F-16 fighter jets
the question of f-16s is really a
question for another Dave White House
officials from the president on down
insist Ukraine doesn't need f-16s what
they need right now are tanks and
armored personnel carriers and infantry
fighting Vehicles artillery and air
defense systems Burns said the U.S does
have to help the ukrainians regain the
upper hand because otherwise Russian
President Vladimir Putin will drag out
the war as long as he can Putin's view
of Americans of us has been that we have
attention deficit disorder and we'll
move on to some other issue eventually
and so Putin in many ways I think
believes today that he cannot win for a
while but he can't afford to lose
well questions and concerns Loom about
China's intentions another world power
is offering assistance to Ukraine Saudi
Arabia has agreed to provide 400 million
dollars worth of Aid this comes after
the Kingdom's foreign minister made a
surprise trip to Kiev yesterday Tony
all right Nancy thank you very much